et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc patrick kanner bonjour merci
beaucoup d'elle marais où nous vous êtes
sénateur du nord continent du groupe
socialiste ici au sénat on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord
ouest comme moi parce qu'on a perdu hier
soir
d'abord l'ukraine bien évidemment
vladimir poutine qui défie les
occidentaux il a reconnu les provinces
séparatistes pro-russes du crâne il y
envoie l'armée dit que les accords de
paix n'existe plus malgré les tentatives
de dialogue des manuels macron la
tension monte est-ce que vous soutenez
le chef de l'état dans ce qu'il a fait
ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il pouvait et ce
qu'ils devaient selon voies emmanuel
macron j'assure que le chef de l'état
devait faire ce qu'ils pouvaient en la
matière chez de l'état ça veut dire en
france chef de la diplomatie chef des
armées et donc le président a fait son
devoir en tant que telle la question
c'est est ce qu'il a réussi la réponse
est non la réponse est non il a été
instrumentalisée manipulée et si je
reprends
l'intervention fière de mon ancien
patron françois hollande il a raison de
dire que avec poutine n'y a pas de
séduction qui marche la france s'est
fait mener en bateau avec poutine il ne
comprend que le rapport de force mais
donc on a péché par naïveté
on peut le dire on peut le dire et moi
je vois ces images terribles
écoutez il a fait son devoir je le
répète simplement
vous avez bien compris je n'étais pas
présent au moment du dieu du dialogue
mais passer des heures et des heures
avec quelqu'un qui vous a regardé comme
un raminagrobis en disant mais vient mon
petit peu via mon petit macron tu vas
voir ce que tu vas voir là ce qui s'est
passé et on vous rappelera vous voyez
vous ces images cette table avec cinq ou
six mètres ou 7 mètres je crois de
distance pour ridiculiser emmanuel
macron qui a accepté mais quand même
cela donc c'est l'image de la france qui
était ternie malheureusement en tout cas
il devait sûrement faire prendre
beaucoup d'initiatives mais en aucune
manière laisser penser qu'il a été
manipulé et il a fait mais la france en
faisant ça probablement globalement la
parole de la france mais il n'y a pas de
prix olaf scholz il a été traité de la
même manière donc avec poutine c'est le
rapport de forces c'est l'engagement
qu'elles aient lequel rapport de force
peut ton engagé parce qu'il ya le
discours même pas martial d'aidé
européen mais qui est donc qui appelle à
des à des sanctions elles commencent
sont discutés à l'heure actuelle elle
commença et commencent également elles
vont toucher la finance se ruent
semaines apparaissent vraiment pas de
nature à faire bouger
la dernière poutine disons le très
clairement nous n'allons pas mourir pour
l'ukraine c'est terrible à dire ça
peut-être mais c'est la réalité d'hier
les deux province autoproclamée de
lougansk et de deux nièces que voilà
vont être de fait annexés pas comme la
crimée en 2014 ce sera des méthodes
différentes mais elles vont être
rattachés à la russie d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que la prochaine étape
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu mais c'est
marioupol wiiu paul c'était une ville
qui est intermédiaire entre la crimée et
ces deux provinces et on va faire un
corridor si vous avez un peu de mémoire
historique et vous en avez ça fait
penser à l'enclos ce l'est sud est le
corridor de dents de scie ch tout cela
si on parlait sud est c'est qu'on prend
on pronostique une guerre mondiale on en
n'est peut-être pas là mais en tout cas
faut pas de l'acheter il faut pas de
l'acheter mais alors que faire n est pas
amende de l'otan il n'ya pas donc de
réciprocité d'intervention l'ukraine
n'est pas membre de l'union européenne
c'est peut-être un problème il demande
d'ailleurs à intégrer l'union européenne
pour être protégé vis-à-vis de l' empire
je crois que c'est une question qu'il
faut se poser le président français et
qui cumule le candidat-président le
président candidat le président de la
république le président du conseil de
l'union européenne peut-être qu'ils
devraient s'interroger d'ailleurs si
l'oeuvre s'il avait dû accepter cette
présidence de l'union européenne s'est
fait comme beaucoup pour un seul homme
et je considère qu'en tout cas cette
question se pose parce que l'ukraine est
aux portes de l'europe institutionnelle
et fait partie finalement de notre
histoire comme un geste un dernier mot
sur les sur les sanctions vladimir
poutine par exemple il est lui même de
la liste des personnes sanctionnées par
l'union
je sais que sa fille a une très très
belle villa près de saint tropez et
qu'on ne touchera pas manifestement
c'est peut-être la prochaine étape
c'est-à-dire de toucher au portefeuille
comme on l'avait fait avec la mafia
américaine à une autre et sont
les américains avec les sanctions qui
touchent la la caisse des dépôts et
consignations rue ce qu'espère en fait
les pays occidentaux c'est qu'en
touchant aux intérêts financiers russes
et aussi aux oligarques bien quelque
part ils soient lâchés parce que le lien
sera pas le cas le lien avec l'argent et
poutine c'est quelque chose quand même
donc peut-être quand même que les
oligarques quand il y aura des sanctions
qui mettront en péril le fait d'aller
pouvoir ne skiez à courchevel de fed
allait pouvoir jouer au casino à monte
carlo peut-être que ils se demanderont
mais est ce que finalement poutine n'est
pas en train de vous emmener dans le mur
votre candidate anne hidalgo tient une
conférence de pression aujourd'hui pour
parler de l'usagé de lieux de l'ukraine
pour dire quoi pour dire je peux être
que je viens de vous dire je ne suis pas
le porte parole donnée hidalgo même si
je suis très proche d'elle mais après
soutien mais je pense pour dire qu' on
ne peut pas laisser l'ukraine seule face
à l'ogre russe et ça passe par une
démarche européenne mais je lui laisse
l'exprimer on dit on dit aussi qu'elle
veut mettre face à ses responsabilités
le dit de jean luc mélenchon face à son
discours qualifié de pro russe où seule
manche en vis-à-vis des dictateurs
qu'ils soient d'amérique du sud qu'ils
soient de russie où qu'ils soient de
chine ce sont des dictatures ou des
démocratures comme on dit mais peu
importe
c'est vrai que là parfois giro mais
j'aime est très variable une analyse
différente sur le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux mêmes manifestement il ya
eu des déclarations sur taïwan qui sont
extrêmement inquiétantes en disant il
n'y a pas très longtemps en disant mais
finalement si taiwan se déclarer
indépendante ne serait pas anormal
finalement que la chine puisse
en tout cas ce que je sais c'est que
l'exemple de poutine peut donner de
mauvaises idées à d'autres dictateurs
dans le monde et c'est tout l'équilibré
finalement institutionnel qui est
menacée dans ce dans cette partie du
monde et moi je suis très inquiet je ne
parle pas de guerre mondiale j'ai évoqué
le sud est mais je ne parle pas de
guerre mondiale mais je trouve quand
même que la faiblesse des démocraties
vis-à-vis de ce type de manoeuvre ce
type d'ambition et bien peut tuer
globalement la démonstration de l'année
mot sur ce sujet est ce que le président
de groupe que vous êtes demandant débat
parlementaire sur cette question on n'a
plus beaucoup de temps pour le faire le
gouvernement aurait pu prendre
l'initiative peut-être nous allons
parler du mali mais bon très très très
honnêtement on n'a plus le temps pour
pour le faire mais néanmoins je lui dis
à votre micro si le président de la
république le gouvernement estimé qu'il
était intéressant d'informer le
parlement de pouvoir ait lieu donc de se
réunir tant que tel bien évidemment nous
serons présents physiquement au
parlement autant que de besoin et
justement on va parler du mali puisque
la y aura un débat cet après midi au
sénat sur la stratégie française au sel
alors que manuel macro annoncé la
semaine dernière le retrait des troupes
françaises d'humaniste c'est un débat
encore utile du coup tout d'abord j'ai
en écoutant votre chaîne dédiée à débat
l'initiative du gouvernement non
juridiquement oui mais pas politiquement
puisque j'ai il ya trois semaines
exactement demandé l'organisation de ce
débat mais quoi de plus normal enfin le
fait qu'avec un président de groupe soit
amené à demander au premier ministre qui
d'ailleurs en cours de séance a eu
l'autorisation par le président de la
république d'organiser ce débat il a
répondu plus tard à christian cambon ça
montre bien qu'il ya une difficulté
alors
le débat 50-1 restera utile où nous
aurons des choses à dire mais il est
vrai que faire un débat une semaine
après la décision de sortir du mali
permettez moi de penser que c'est encore
une mauvaise manière vis-à-vis du
parlement aurait dû alors il aurait
fallu partir plus tôt comme le comme l'a
soutenu françois hollande en tout cas
notre place n'est plus au mali
il a fallu un débat au parlement qui
aurait permis de prendre une telle
décision plutôt si on respecte si on
devait respecter le parlement ce qui
n'est pas le cas vous le savez donc oui
le aujourd'hui depuis cinq ans il y à un
délitement je dis bien depuis cinq ans
je ne jette pas la pierre au président
de la république actuel mais il est vrai
qu'à la fin du quinquennat de françois
hollande nous étions encore les
bienvenus au mali ce qui n'est plus le
cas depuis maintenant de nombreux mois
de nombreuses et bien votre chandail
il ya eu certes un putsch et pourquoi y
at il eu un putsch fait la question de
la france non
mais mais ça signifie que quelque part
que l'engagement des avions pris de
d'augmenter j'ai envie dire laura
démocratique au sein du mali d'aidé au
développement du mali pour lui permettre
justement d'éviter de voir des
militaires se prendre la tête pour dire
mais on va prendre le pouvoir tout ceci
peut-être n'a pas été fait suffisamment
et depuis cinq ans on a eu une présence
militaire point barre et pas
suffisamment de développement économique
du mali et de la zone sahel en tant que
tel parce que le meilleur antidote face
à des ch face aux extrémismes faso junte
c'est le développement économique
en tout cas d absence regrettable est
aujourd'hui le président de république
soeur du mali en disant mais on restera
quand même au sahel la france est bien
bien sûr mais je n'ai en écusson la même
logique sur la russie je trouve que la
parole diplomatique de la france
aujourd'hui pèse moins qu'elle ne pose
est historiquement
en tout cas dans toutes les hypothèses
il aura peu d'occasions
d'en débattre parce que il procrastine
sa déclaration de candidature avec les
arguments internationale pour vous il a
pas raison quand on voit la situation
internationale est ce qu'on dit mais
finalement il a eu raison ne pas se
déclarer sitôt est-ce que là il aurait
mis un drain président en campagne vu la
situation écouter la les institutions
font que nous avons aujourd'hui un
président de la république quitte en
fonction jusqu'à la dernière minute mais
qui est face à une campagne électorale
potentiel il a décalé continue à décaler
j'espère qu'il sera quand même qui
n'oubliera pas que le 4 mars et la fin
quoi et que finalement il ya une
élection présidentielle parce qu'on peut
aussi en jambes et l'élection
présidentielle
bien sûr toute la stratégie de chez
makro on sait qu'ils puissent avec un
temps très court ne pas avoir à rendre
des comptes et bien moi je dis à votre
micro que le président de rendre des
comptes y compris sur sa politique
internationale et être des deux
candidats un mois avant l'élection
présidentielle dont il a choisi la date
je vous le rappelle dire on aurait pu
imaginer parce qu'on dira oui lui mais
ça marche pas j'ai déjà eu des élections
pendant des jours fériés donc en fait on
nous avons à peine un mois de campagne
réel au moment de la déclaration du
président de la république quand il le
décidera et ça c'est une atteinte au bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions c'est
une guerre éclate et selon vous trahit
là le message démocratique en tout cas
peut-être qu'on est en train de nous
voler l'élection présidentielle le
président qui veulent la campagne et
l'élection
s'il n'est pas candidat et s'il ne
présente pas son bilan et s'ils
continuent à utiliser les moyens de
l'état il ya quelque chose qui ne colle
pas
mais comme je le dis souvent métaphore
cinématographique la raim south beach
house tout la moc la marque ronis hausse
tous à ça qu'on les reconnaît
oui parce que le premier ministre jean
castex qui a demandé aux élus hier alors
il est l assemblée d'accorder leur leur
parrainage l'horreur rappeler quand même
qu'il y avait en effet parrainage de ne
signifiait pas soutient il invite les
associations d'élus ainsi que les
présidents du sénat et de l'assemblée
demain pour évoquer la question est ce
que c'est une bonne initiative
monsieur l'écuyer deuxième métaphore
choteau graphique est ce qu a dit
christian clavier dans les visiteurs
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce binz
alors pourquoi mais qu'est ce que vient
faire l'exécutif dans cette affaire des
parrainages
grèce que j'en pense mais à nous sommes
à une semaine de la fin de la procédure
une semaine avant la procédure le
premier ministre convoque les deux
présidents de chambre les présidents et
présidentes d'associations delhi pour
leur dire à déni je prends pas l'accent
juste pas le faire un déni de démocratie
il faut quand même que tout le monde
puisse candidater mais qui tout le monde
un modèle bayrou avec son sa braderie
n'ont pas de lille mais sa braderie des
parrainages quand même des parrainages
la braderie mais bien sûr j'aime
braderie petit bébé choisi ses candidats
à duras très oui mais mais mais mais
quelques dizaines ou centaines je ne
sais pas de de parrainage potentiel on
les donnera à ce qui peut vraiment
postuler mais en
quoi la candidature à mme taubira
est moins légitime que celle de monsieur
zemmour on soutient les fachos plutôt
que des gens qui ont une vision
démocratique de la société et pour vous
il n'y a pas de problème avec justement
ce système de parer d'or je termine
d'abord mon argument et je vous dit ce
que j'en pense donc monsieur castex n'a
pas à se mêler de cette question à une
semaine c'est de la tambouille c'est de
l'abus de tripatouillage et le seul
objectif c'est de permettre à le pen et
azemmour d'avoir leur parrainage parce
qu'il ne veut pas se retrouver avec
macron devant madame pécresse parce que
mme pécresse peut battre monsieur macron
ce qui est peut-être moins le cas 2
de zemmour ou 2 ou de le pen moi je
préfère histoire hidalgo qui bat macron
mais ça c'est un autre débat alors oui
mais qu'elle est mort et ses parrainages
il faut pas les éluder je ne dis pas
cela
nous nous disons que nous avons une
candidate et nous poussons les nôtres à
soutenir notre candidate
les parrainages ont pas écoutés que les
élus le dfid ça c'est leur problème mais
que l'exécutif s'en mêle et pour moi un
scandale d'état l'exécutif n'a pas à se
mêler séparation des pouvoirs il y a une
constitution il ya des lois organiques
cette règle est une règle sûrement
qu'ils doivent adapter et je lui dit à
mathieu castex pour répondre à votre
deuxième question
nous avons proposé en février 2021 éric
kerrouche qui est monsieur élections
dans notre groupe a proposé dans le
cadre d'une loi organique sur l'élection
présidentielle de modifier les règles de
parrainage en proposant un mixte très
simple non pas 500 parrainages d'élus
mais deux cent cinquante et cent
cinquante mille soutien citoyen
clairement identifiés avec des règles
pour que les choses ne soient pas
manipuler bien évidemment donc et qu'est
ce qu'a dit gouvernement à l'époque
passé il n'y a rien à voir comme
d'ailleurs nous a dit sur le vote par
correspondance passé il n'y a rien à
voir comme l'a dit sur le vote soit 3
jours passent et il n'a rien à voir donc
ce gouvernement depuis cinq ans est
prévenue archi prévenus notamment par le
groupe socialiste au sénat qu'il y a un
problème démocratique dans notre pays et
maintenant une semaine avant la fin des
personnages il dit man ray y sont nova
ce qu'il me soit une version alors
j'entends ce que vous dites mais annie
de chocolat bien sûr je l'entends
hidalgo étaient même plus loin dans une
vidéo à france inter c'est à dire qu
elle l a estimé que le un parrainage ne
pouvait pas être donnée à une personne
qu'elle a qualifié de fasciste et
raciste est-ce que c'est pas une aussi
de là une façon pour elle de d'influer
sur justement là
la position des parents potentiels tomas
l'amygdale go est candidate elle a le
droit de dire ce qu'elle pense des
autres candidats monsieur zemmour est un
néo fasciste la maison bon est-ce
qu'elle a raison mais en tout cas moi je
considère que dire ce qu'est réellement
un candidat oui
mais c'est leur responsabilité
moi j'ai un danger un sénateur dont je
tairai le nom qui va soutenir monsieur
poutou voilà parce qu'il estime que en
conscience j'ai envie de ces prêts mais
chaque élu est responsable il ya
quarante deux mille élus le fait que un
candidat n'arrive pas avoir 500
signatures sur un corps électoral entre
guillemets de 42000 une montre bien
qu'il y a un problème et je reprends ce
qu'ils disaient sur un tweet eu durant
son vice-président de la semaine
nationale en disant mais finalement le
problème démocratique elle sait pas que
des gens n'est pas leur signature mais
c'est parce que des élus considèrent qu'
il faut pas donner leur signature à des
gens qui menacent la démocratie et au
grand show a raison
oui anne hidalgo qui dans l'est dans les
sondages est désormais dépassé par le
communiste fabien roussel
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire je me
simplement rappelé que si fabien roussel
arrivé devant anne hidalgo au premier
tour de la présidentielle ce serait la
première fois qu'un communiste dépasse
un socialiste depuis vous connaissez la
date c'est de puiser
voilà alors ce serait exceptionnel je ne
sais pas si ce serait une réussite
attendez tout d'abord les sondages les
vrais sondages vont arriver au moment de
la déclaration officielle de candidature
des uns des autres premièrement
deuxièmement vous savez comment sont
constitués les sondages je vous renvoie
vers un grand journal du soir qui a
décrypté la manière dont cela est fait
donc les panels sont je dirais organisé
à réorganiser on est en train de
fabriquer l'opinion publique dans ce
dans ce pays donc je ne dis pas qu'il
n'ya pas des tendances mais que dire
rowling après rowling de 2000 points en
demi point voilà la réalité de la vie
politique française rendez vous le 10
avril monsieur l'écuyer nous faisons
campagne et je ne crois pas un seul
instant que madame hidalgo soit 2,2 et
demi 3 % voilà je vous le dis comment
penser qu'il est à combien je me bats
vous verrons bien je me bats il ya une
campagne s'il ya une campagne électorale
c'est parce qu'on estime que ça peut
faire bouger les lignes et dans ce cadre
très simplement on est en train de dire
mais finalement à quoi sert une élection
à quoi sert une campagne puisque tout
est dit dans les sondage de l'ifop duck
sauce des larmes les sondages ne disent
pas a contrario est ce que les sondages
ne disent pas quelque chose comme vous
dites
tendances donnent une tendance et cette
tendance est plutôt baissière du côté de
hidalgo elle est plutôt en dynamique du
baht et de fabien roussel pour ça veut
dire que concrètement la campagne d'anne
hidalgo souffre d'un problème la
campagne d'ali ziri la campagne a
commencé un peu à la commençons la
critique était la campagne va commencer
oui elle a commencé vous savez à quoi
vous dire quand même quelques on sera
vraiment comme un conte sera candidat
d'accord vient malheureusement il
restera trop trop peu de temps mais nous
nous continuons le programme va être
diffusé dans des millions de boîtes aux
lettres à partir de début mars je vais
organiser puisque ce mon rôle dans la
campagne
577 réunions publiques une dans chaque
circonscription pendant un mois du 8 9
mars au 8 9 avril une dans chaque
circonscription réunions publiques plus
les meetings plus les débats et nous
verrons que nous allons passer de la
période de l'affirmation de la
candidature qui je vous rappelle a
obtenu déjà près de 12 cents signatures
ont parlé des parrainages de ce qui a
manqué mais permettez moi de rappeler
quand même khalid legault est très
largement soutenu très largement soutenu
c'est aussi une forme de chômage elle et
elle est soutenue mais pas par tout le
monde vous avez lu évidemment que vous
avez vu comme moi entendu ségolène royal
qui dit que le seul vote utile c'est
jean luc mélenchon alors c'est quoi de
la part de ségolène j'ai lu dans la
presse que l'aed refusé de désirs
d'avenir à désir de nuire savez c'est la
noya la soutient emmanuel macron puis
après l'a soutenu madame pécresse
elle soutenait le parti socialiste quand
elle voulait être sénatrice et peut-être
que vous l'auriez eu à ce plateau à ma
place parce que l'ambition est grande
chez madame royal donc elle soutient
aujourd'hui mélenchon bas j'en veux dire
regarde dans le prochain épisode pour
savoir que la boussole de madame royal
est manifestement soumise à beaucoup de
force de tentatrice mais est ce qu'elle
est ce que sur les faits alors au delà
en effet des expressions de ségolène
royal mais est-ce qu'elle n'a pas raison
dans les faits c'est à dire que le seul
candidat capable de faire gagner la
gauche à l'heure actuelle au premier
tour
c'est jean luc mélenchon et bien moi je
réponds à l'amour hayal qui d'ailleurs a
très peu de soutien je répands le mont
royal que soutient monsieur mélenchon
cette gauche protestataire incantatoire
qui est capable de défiler avec les
frères musulmans ce n'est pas ma gauche
et donc je lui dis très simplement non
seulement nous sommes en concurrence à
gauche à l'extrême gauche en
l'occurrence pour monsieur mélenchon
avec ce qu'il représente en termes
d'idées mais que je combats une très
grande partie il ya des choses qui me
conviennent donc pouvoir d'achat des
drames et je combats fortement les
engagements de monsieur mélenchon qui me
semble dangereux y compris en terme de
laïcité un autre soutien qu'on a qu'on
attend c'est celui de françois hollande
invité de bfm tv hier n'a pas réussi à
dire qu'il voterait pour anne hidalgo à
la présidentielle alors est-ce que c'est
pas un peu quand même agaçant ce flou
entretenu par l'ancien président si vous
êtes honnêtes des boulettes jeu il a dit
mais je me suis déjà exprimé sur le
sujet point barre mais pourquoi ne pas
l'avoir il vient
et bien la réponse va être flagrant
puisque je vous confirme que françois
hollande sera présent lors d'un prochain
meeting de madame hidalgo meeting
surprise
là sont ce qu'ils sont mais il y à des
meetings voilà prévue à rennes à limoges
à toulouse alliés
oui vous choisirez vous choisirez
peut-être c'est peut-être pour ça non
mais c'est au sein des socialistes est
plus emploi plus en plus de voix qui
s'élèvent pour demander une refondation
du parti après l'élection présidentielle
je suis voilà et le parti socialiste
doit-il disparaître pour sauver le
socialisme vous savez le ps n'a jamais
disparu il a il a connu le congrès de
tours il a survécu aux communistes
congrès de tours qui était majoritaire
c'est en 1926 est vrai que vous n'y
était pas nier non plus d'ailleurs
rigoureuse
le
il a il a survécu à la fin de l'essai
fillon est en lien avec la guerre
d'algérie pour faire le nouveau parti
socialiste et après le parti socialiste
qu'il faudra
je considère que la page d'épinés est
tournée mais dans le même livre du
socialisme français cegedim français
fait partie de notre vie politique
depuis maintenant reclus plus d'un
siècle et je considère que la création
d'épinés la pression du ps à epinay
trois ans après 68 n'oubliez pas et est
basé essentiellement sur nouveau droit
nouvelle liberté ça a permis d'avoir
changé la vie le programme commun etc
aujourd'hui les politiques ont changé
les nouveaux droits nouvelle liberté
c'est toujours important la lutte contre
lisez minorité sociale ça reste
essentiel dans le combat politique mais
la question de la république jusqu'au
bout la question du développement
durable aussi juste pour les plus
pauvres se pose et il faut rebâtir notre
vision idéologique et moi je ferais
partir tout cas je le souhaite de cette
reconstruction non pas qu en
construction pour acter une disparition
mais pour une transformation le phénix
la résurrection mais
patrick hannais on regarde la une de la
voix du nord julien c'est le ras-le-bol
des agriculteurs et celle il pas de
miracle pour le losc à chelsea vous êtes
optimiste pour le match retour patrick
kanner c'est 2 à
0 à l'aller ça veut dire 3 0 et au
retour oui c'est un peu compliqué mais
je serai j'espère présent le 16 mars
mais si la campagne me le permets
sondages sont colossaux
[Musique]